The highly anticipated second trailer for
Captain Marvel gave fans a closer look at
Brie Larson as Carol Danvers and her fabulous,
occasionally mohawked superhero alter-ego
Captain Marvel, even more eyepatch-less Nick
Fury, and teased an awesome-looking space
battle sequence.
There was a lot to love in the newest sneak
peek - but one clip does a bit more heavy
lifting than the rest, solving a minor MCU
mystery.
We know that Captain Marvel tells Carol Danvers'
origin story, and to do that without making
even more of a mess out of the existing Marvel
Cinematic Universe timeline, directors Anna
Fleck and Ryan Boden are rolling the clock
back 23 years and introducing the hero in
1995.
It's an exciting choice, but it was also somewhat
confusing, since Carol Danvers is also lined
up to appear in Avengers 4, which is set in
the here and now.
If Captain Marvel is set more than 20 years
prior to the events of the Infinity War sequel,
wouldn't that mean she would be middle-aged
by the time she shows up in the forthcoming
film?
And if she isn't pushing 50 in Avengers 4
and does appear in the film in the same youthful
form that she does in her solo movie, which
is the most likely outcome, does that signal
time travel is to thank for her involvement?
That doesn't appear to be the case.
The newest trailer appears to reveal the real
reason for Carol's perpetually youthful appearance:
it's the result of the accident that left
her human body imbued with DNA from the alien
race known as the Kree, first introduced in
the MCU in Agents of SHIELD and Guardians
of the Galaxy.
In the trailer, we see Annette Bening appear
as an unnamed, mystery character who explains
to Carol her Kree origins, telling her that
the Kree rescued her when she was in trouble
and couldn't remember who she was.
"We made you one of us.
So you could live longer, stronger, superior."
To the average watcher, those lines might
not hold much weight.
Yeah, of course Captain Marvel is physically
powerful and superior to humans whose DNA
isn't comprised of half Kree genetics!
That's the kind of stuff that makes superheroes
superheroes!
But this clip implies that Carol will outlive
regular humans and will age at a significantly
slower rate, perhaps explaining why she will
barely have gotten any older between the time
of her accident in Captain Marvel and when
she heads back to Earth in Avengers 4.
Marvel diehards probably already knew all
of this - Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D., for just
one example, addresses the phenomenal longevity
of the Kree - but more casual Marvel moviegoers
were likely confused before this revelation.
Someone who will feel the effects of time,
however, is Nick Fury.
Marvel digitally de-aged Samuel L. Jackson's
character for the entirety of Captain Marvel,
but he'll be his old self again - literally!
- in time for Avengers 4.
By the time Nick pages Carol for back-up in
the post-credits scene in Infinity War, he's
sporting some wrinkles and his signature patch
over his eye.
Even with this plot hole-clearing, there's
still much about Captain Marvel fans have
yet to discover.
Like, what's up with "Goose" the cat?
Is Pulp Fiction available at that Blockbuster,
making this a Last Action Hero situation?
"No!
It isn't possible!"
"What's not possible?
He's fantastic!"
Who is Annette Bening playing, and will she
ever run into Michael Douglas in the MCU,
giving American President fans the reunion
they crave?
Does Carol smack down any other suspicious
septuagenarians, or just subway lady?
So many questions!
The good news is that fans won't have to wait
too much longer for answers.
Captain Marvel soars into theaters on March
8th, 2019.